parabelflug herzlich willkommen wir
heute meine lieben freunde endlich zur
zweiten episode vom untitled gruß gelben
ja dann kannst du nur geil werden in der
ersten folge vom anteil der fußgänger
habe ich euch gesagt dass ihm den namen
für diese ganz und in die kommentare
schreiben sollte und gewonnen hat dieser
kommentar also die ganze zeit ab sofort
sandra da kann man auch ein paar
klatschen reger ich würde sagen gerufen
erst mal wieder unsere aufgaben auf und
zwar müssen wir den gärtner immer noch
nass machen als allererstes das heißt
ich oh mein gott er steht gerade hier
steht eine neue aufgabe wir haben hier
ganz unten jetzt eine neue aufgabe
bekommen und zwar bringen den gärtner
dazu sich mit dem hammer auf den daumen
zu schlagen hört sich überhaupt nicht
kompliziert an keine ahnung wie ich das
machen soll aber erst mal noch ganz
viele von euch zu mir den kommentaren
dass ich hier mir einen extra eingang
bauen kann und zwar soll ich einfach
hier die kiste wegnehmen und dann kann
ich glaube ich hier durch hobby zu fett
sandra kopp also wir sind jetzt im
garten und haben diesmal einen zweiten
eingang hier vorne ist der hammer wie
wirke ich mich nochmal so okay ich habe
den hammer das heißt der typen muss mich
jetzt gehen sie mit diesem einmal hier
schlagen
ich weiß auch nicht wie wir das machen
sollen sandra der name sandra passt
eigentlich ziemlich gut zu der ganz weil
die ganze ein bisschen auf mallorca
kommt kommt dass man meint dass meine
mama etwas mau jetzt der typ hat sein
hammer dort wieder hingelegt und er hat
sogar ein schild aufgebaut wo er mich
durch gestrichen hat wie soll ich ihnen
denn ja ja du kannst noch mal sagen ja
los also hier vorne steht vom schild
auch das kannst du das kannst du gar
mitnehmen der penner so das wäre ja
schönen see schmeißen
das kommt dabei raus wenn lukas anteil
des games spielt und zack das hast du
gut erkannt sandra ich hab so ein
bisschen die hoffnung dass der typ
gleich merkt hey das schild fehlt und
dann denkt er sich das ist im see
dann geht er zum see holt das schild und
dann will er das wieder reinhauen mit
dem hammer und dann kann ich irgendwie
dabei stört
ein paar sekunden später hat verfolgt
der mich denn jetzt ja ja hpc ich
verstecke mich einfach mal hier in dem
dings kann ich auch meinen kopf hinweg
[Musik]
wo es dann ratsam
dieses spiel beschreibt mein youtube
konnte nicht einfach perfekt also der
typ checkt jetzt gerade das ein schild
irgendwie weg ist und ich ja damit
nichts zu tun hat was ist denn seine
mission hier ja wat willste guckt wie
hier so an als wäre ich hier ja nee
sandra meine fresse wie soll der typ
denn jetzt auch das schild auf
[Musik]
ich glaub den mit dem radio anlauf
sandra oh mein gott ihr müsst mich als
er gleich weg durch ok perfekt okay wir
sind hier durch das heißt wir haben das
radio und jetzt andere ganz ganz ganz
ganz schnell das radio schmeißen wir
jetzt hier in den griff
so heißt der typ kommt so sein radio
mein gott ich hätte es zu dem schild
schmeißen müssen der gärtner nicht zum
schild kommen will dann kommt das schild
zum gärtner mein gott ok kommen schlägt
ihm das jetzt hier hin der muss jetzt
auch dieses verdammte schild deggendorf
er hat er sieht das schild hier das
schild hier vorne genau perfekt sodass
nimmt jetzt mit hier vorne hin genau ich
darf schon mal ein bisschen vor und
jetzt können wir den gärtner glaube ich
ablenken mit sehen wir sie nicht
ablenken sondern wenn er das schild
wieder reinhaut versuche ich dann
irgendwie
[Musik]
er trägt sein schild und stellte wieder
auf die ecke denkt an den hammer ok
und jetzt wenn er da rein haut werde ich
ihnen meine damen und herren er gerne
denkt schon wieder nur in seine komische
kühlbox das heißt wir werden jetzt
einmal schnell durch diese tür hierdurch
und sehen schon wir sind in einem neuen
abschnitt
was ist hier ja sandra was denkst immer
noch ein bratwurst hier ist irgendwie
nichts los ich weiß nicht was man hier
machen soll
wir laufen deswegen einfach mal ein
stückchen weiter hier steht ein auto
hier ist eine pfütze
da können wir dann schön hier ist die
welt auf jeden fall ein bisschen
zivilisiert haben hier ist ein typ mit
einem ja der im schuppen blöd gucken
slater was will dieser junge kannst du
dich nicht mehr verpassen
er springt er hoch ihr sollt ihr wieder
nach davor den und ich sage jeden moment
kommt er wieder zurückgelaufen guckt da
kommt ja wieder
jetzt gibt er mich wieder an der spree
wieder hoch und läuft wieder weg keine
ahnung was hier vor sich geht wir haben
hier auf jeden fall irgendwie so ein
wochenmarkt hier vorne haben wir haben
neue aufgaben als wir haben hier immer
noch die letzten aufgaben von einem
gärtner vorhinein zu bringen dazu den
sonnen du zu tragen habe ich weiß
wirklich nicht wie wir das schaffen
sollen dann können wir allerdings nach
rechts zweiten und dann sehen wir schon
wir haben neue aufgaben und schwarz der
bericht den besen
wie soll ich denn besen zerbrechen also
zunächst einmal müssen wir dafür jan
besen finden hier sind halt relativ
viele gegenstände hier ist allerdings
kein besen da es nun rächen dabei hier
vorne passiert ebenfalls nichts dass
auch keinen ding hier ist wieder der
junge und jetzt auf den weg und hier
steht einer pfütze ja auch audi läuft
immer nächste aufgabe war nämlich glaube
ich den jungen in einer telefonzelle
einzusperren
das heißt wir suchen uns erstmal telefon
zeit und dann los mit den jungen dahin
durch unser geschnatter 2000 jahre
später
okay da die telefonzelle das heißt ich
gehe jetzt einfach von der seite hier zu
dem jungen dann da sagt schnell
irgendwas um ihn zu verscheuchen zum
beispiel dafür
genau so macht der junge läuft in die
telefonzelle am bass haha ich war total
erbricht den besen das ist unsere
nächste aufgabe und ich bin allerdings
immer noch ein bisschen auf dem schlauch
da ist der besen okay die muss ich
irgendwie klar dem besen bruder geht mir
dem event bringen den jungen dazu die
falsche brille zu tragen ist die nächste
aufgabe das heißt wir rennen wieder hier
außen rum ich wusste gleich dass der typ
überhaupt eine brille trägt und wie
sollen wir behaupten dazu bringen die
falsche brille zu tragen also da ist der
junge und brille
fussball ich habe kann ich den kann ich
den
ich kann den fußball nicht mal nehmen
hier ist eine wasserflasche ja auch
keine ahnung was ich damit machen soll
hier bitteschön dieser scheiß junge kann
ich hier rein
hallo seiner wachse wasser das sind nur
gerade weil es wirklich nicht wesentlich
jetzt gerade machen soll
der typ macht seine tür nicht auf kann
nämlich nicht reinlassen mach ich denn
jetzt hier kommen die flasche finde ich
freue mich doch mal als läuft er wieder
weg wird im fernsehen auf ich nehme
jetzt einfach mal meinen fußball und
rolle denen hier vor und jetzt hatte ich
die ganze zeit vielleicht sich der typ
mit dem fußballspielen hallo keine typ
ich will das fernsehen ich gehe jetzt
mal mit der komischen ja vielleicht ja
damit kann der x
oder ist das der falsche weg
du willst eine krawatte mit de einkaufen
läge in den korb zahnbürste klopapier
haarbürste konservendosen
reinigungsmittel obst und gemüse wenn
ich einkaufe gekauft eigentlich nur
pizza ihre das ding ist dass wir dafür
erstmal corp brauchen der steht hier
allerdings kann ich den nicht mitnehmen
ich probiere jetzt erstmal mit der
karotte ich wollte die kaufen probiert
halt mit der anderen karotte hier habe
die schmiede lebte ja gibt die karotte
ein alter das kann nicht sein dass die
so wird schnell die ganze zeit ist mir
die karotten wieder abnehmen kann es
also das ding ist was ich mich halt
immernoch frage ist und dass immer noch
in meinem kopf drin hängt diese
challenge ist wie soll der typ eine
andere brille tragen
[Musik]
die schleiche mich jetzt mal ganz leise
hier annehmen die brille haus schnell ab
und geben im typen hier die brille genau
recht sie ihn an und jetzt nimmt auch
die brille ich bringe die brille einfach
hier in das ding rein und jetzt
erschrecke ich den jungen so dass er
denkt dass er in dem in den den jacken
genau wie so ruft er denn jetzt
er hat ihn jetzt angerufen und er kommt
er zu mir
die frau was macht sie denn jetzt her
kann ich jetzt hier ein hoch
hallo hauer tritt im fernsehen auf
allerdings bin ich das heute wieder
sauber enden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch dieser zweite teil von luca spielt
an teilte games- sie mit whatever
gefallen hat dann was unbedingt einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier dabei
50.000 like kommt nächste woche der
dritte teil dieser serie
du denkst nur ein fußball da muss man
dicke brille hier da die brille und er
läuft wieder einfach nur weg die mir
ersten teil dieser serie auch bereits
schon gesagt haben wenn ihr tipps für
mich hab was die aufgaben stellen jazz
angeht dann schreibt sie auf jeden fall
gerne und in die kommentare abonniert
zudem gerne meinen kanal falls sie noch
kein luxus sei die verpassen dadurch
keine videos mehr das ist kostenlos und
wenn schon dann klicken auf die glocke
dann bekommt er eine benachrichtigung
auf euer handy oder wird einfach wenig
neues video hochladen und jetzt kommt
auch das auto
[Musik]